dating an entrepreneur could either be
the most exhilarating thing you ever do
in your life or it could absolutely
drive you insane if you don't know how
entrepreneurs are wired so today's
episode I want to cover two different
things there's two audiences I'm
speaking to today one I want to speak to
the entrepreneur who they asked and they
say private message they Pat I would
love for my partner to understand why
I'm why the way I'm what do I do
what book do I recommend what article do
I share with them the purpose of this
video is for you to say honey watch this
this is how I am as an entrepreneur
bait watch this this is how I am as an
entrepreneur and the second thing is you
may be dating somebody who's an
entrepreneur all your life you've been
dating somebody who maybe as an employee
come homes 9:00 to 5:00 and all of us in
your thing about dating a guy or girl
who's an entrepreneur you're kind of
like wait a minute they're very
different why is this happening do they
have problems is this guy
psychologically off what the heck is
going on here and you're confused
hopefully this soul you know give you a
little bit of clarity why they're wire
the way they are so let me get right
into it okay so I'm gonna share with you
15 things you should know before dating
an entrepreneur okay
15 things point number one entrepreneurs
are very very weird and you need to know
this in advance what do I mean by very
very weird so let's talk about
personality wise you can talk to them
one moment and they are so happy I mean
it's amazing how happy they are and then
next thing you know an hour later
they're emotionally crying it just
nothing happened or just all of a sudden
very emotional and then the next thing
you know they're ticked off they're
absolutely ticked off what the heck just
happened here well the brain is wired
like that because they'll typically be a
little bit more sensitive to things
because they take things very little
than everybody else like to them it's
like I can't believe this just happen
and they go deep and emotions up up and
then they feel it where somebody's like
oh who cares I don't care what they
think and their mind is wired like that
they could you could you could have
three different people you're seeing at
the same time when you win an
entrepreneur knows what does this mean
they're bipolar or not that's
he's bipolar although if you haven't
read hypomanic edge or if you haven't
read first rate madness these are great
books it'll give you a very good idea of
how some of the entrepreneurs are wired
but just know that it's not the same
person you're dating all the time
something could happen at any point that
they'll shift their thinking now keep
this in mind it may be more exaggerated
when someone's 20 20 to 21 years old but
then it'll get settled down a little bit
more 35 34 maybe even more than that
because it's maturity you learn how to
control your emotions but you're going
to see a lot more this happy sad ticked
off emotion earlier age 10 later on
because that matures and it get better
at that now point number two if you date
an entrepreneur you know generally it's
either bust or all-in there's rarely in
the middle so if you're dating somebody
and during the most horses I dated
several girls who at that time logically
it was probably the best decision making
not dating me because I was absolutely
broke absolutely broke I mean I didn't
have money to pay for gas I didn't have
money to pay for movies I don't have
money to pay for nothing Friday night
I'd rather stay home because I can't
afford to go to the movie so we'd go to
Blockbuster and get a movie or watch the
same movie 50 times over and over and
over again and I'd have to sell them why
I want to spend more time with you but
there is a certain level of delayed
gratification that most people at least
rarely get a chance to experience
because when you're dating an
entrepreneur we typically tend to weigh
them for where they are today right so
if somebody is broke today we think are
going to be broke forever that's not the
case there's a three to five year period
that there's a lot of pain financially
until all of a sudden victory starts
showing up and most people and this is
not a good or bad thing most people
cannot handle this most people would
rather show up here and get someone but
if you can get through this phase with
that person that the entrepreneur male
or female figure whether this person
that's building their business if we can
get through this phase together and you
grow you have a certain loyalty from
them that it's indescribable because
entrepreneurs also understand a lot of
people play the role and then become
successful and they feel indebted to the
Royalton because there's so many haters
so many people that are pushing you
around that you really really really
appreciate people that has your back
when you have nothing so there's going
to be a delayed gratification there's
not consistent cash flow don't expect to
have you know four person makes 50 grand
one month it could quite likely make
very likely make 16 grand the next month
and then four grand and then twenty nine
thousand and seven thousand and twenty
two thousand so just because somebody
made fifty thousand and a month isn't
it's going to happen every single month
that's part of entrepreneurial life so
know that there's a delayed
gratification with the type of income
they have three this is confusing
sometimes they need solitude at times
they need solitude at times now why is
that the Dana soliton I mean you may say
but everybody needs this I'm not talking
about prayer or meditation in the
morning sometimes they just want to be
away from everybody okay and they need
to just have a break for a day it's not
a month or two months or a week it's a
day sometimes it could be four hours
sometimes it could be they're not going
doing anything else they just need a
break because as an entrepreneur your
product is people your product is
numbers and people change so often that
the motion of an entrepreneurs council
going all over the place so something
just kind of need a break and if someone
doesn't know it they may think is he
seeing somebody else is she saying
something notes they just need solitude
sometimes they need a break sometimes
they need to gain back their sanity
sometimes you'll typically hear a lot of
entrepreneurs say on Sundays they sleep
ten hours or twelve hours yeah you hear
so many of these stories you know I just
sleep so many hours on a Sunday because
I sleep four hours every day throughout
the weeks of my Sundays refueling that
could happen sometimes sometimes it
could be a way out of gym at a quiet
place just want to work and train put
music and didn't want to hear anything
talk to anybody because they just need
that piece it could be yoga could be in
a place they need to go to to feel by
themselves so this isn't if someone
doesn't understand this someone could be
offended by and a jealous person may say
well wait a minute how come it's not me
how come it's not about me how comes as
this has nothing to do with who their
day they just want to be alone little
bit to gain back their sanity it
actually helps a partner out if they
understand this part next
point number four they don't live by the
9 to 5 schedule so if if a lot of times
and I had some stats on this I don't
know if I pulled it up I pulled it up
here I'll bring you back up I pulled it
up here on some numbers I'll give you if
you are accustomed to dating people that
are 9 to 5 you are now going to get a 9
to 5 with an entrepreneur by the way if
he does call my 5 o'clock that's not an
entrepreneur he just says he's an
entrepreneur but he's not an
entrepreneur if she comes on at 5
o'clock and they leave at 9 and they
worked the traditional line to fight
that could be an executive that could be
an executive of a company but it's not
an entrepreneur you can talk to any
entrepreneur start a founder they'll
tell you that it's not an entrepreneur
entrepreneurs are they're going nonstop
you're going they're going they're going
so if you want them to come home at 5:00
and watch some shows with you at night
very rarely will you get somebody who's
in the game in the hunt to want to do
that now there's obviously different
levels of entrepreneurs somebody could
get their business to a point where
they're making 200 grand and they're
very comfortable at 200 grand they want
to come home at that time and their goal
was to give to $200,000 your income so
they can't come home at 5 o'clock that's
a goal that's totally fine then there
may be a guy that's you want to get to
million dollar you'll come and do that
and then there's somebody that's
absolutely not driven by money they're
driven by creating things and this is
never going to stop never going to stop
that's the true entrepreneur that the
outcome has nothing to do with a dollar
sign the outcome has to do with this is
how I'm wired I have to create for the
rest of my life to live in this body and
live in this mind and there's nothing I
can do about it this doesn't mean I
don't love you I'm just always in the
hunt and some people don't like that but
you got to know that in advance on what
that entrepreneur is wired to do because
nine-to-five is not going to work so
what's the solution for it if they if
you are dating an entrepreneur they like
schedules put a date and a schedule
truly babe this Friday we're going out
on a date perfect let's put it and then
re remind them do I need to really
remind yes if they have an assistant
stay very close to the assistant system
to remind them that that thought yes
schedule hey on this day babe kids okay
don't forget yes hey can you remind
yes hey don't forget in July we're going
to Hawaii yes
hey don't forget December its Aspen we
talked about this for the last yes
calendar schedule okay that's the part
that you gotta having schedules point
number five and it's similar to but it's
not they usually never clock out this
point number five they usually never
clock that you may be at a dinner at a
restaurant and you're sitting down and
having dinner and all of a sudden all of
a sudden they may go and do something
like this and you may say be what are
you doing babe I'm talking what are you
doing babe babe oh yeah what's it Wepa
me they were were you for the last 20
seconds babe um I'm right here baby what
he talkin about
but baby I was asking you three times
you didn't you babe I'm so sorry I was
sitting right in front you but they're
thinking they're minding this government
because they could have sat at a
restaurant and seen something the
manager did to an assistant that gave
him an idea to add that to their office
to have that as an expectation gave him
an idea to talk to one of their
executives and share this idea with them
and they're gone completely gone so you
may take it as he never pays any
attention to me it's just how they're
wired sometimes now they got to work on
it I'm not trying to give them all these
alibis but that's just kind of how they
are okay and you know that's how they
are you may be sitting on a Sunday
you're sitting there or watching a movie
and all of a sudden they'll get up and
they're gone for 30 minutes and they're
working on something right there what
are you doing it's just had an idea to
work on something they'll come back
they're never off their mind always goes
they could be sleeping at that middle
night two o'clock in the morning they
wake up and I go type something out for
one hour that's a true entrepreneur I am
way that's how they're wired
if something's wired in a way you know
that's just how they're wired there's
nothing you can do about the wiring and
if you change the wiring you cut it you
change them you kill them and you don't
want that either right so you know
there's there's net they rarely ever
clock out what number six
they don't do very well with ultimatums
let me tell what I mean by ultimatums
for instance um I got a call from one of
my friends from many many many years ago
growing up and he said you know he's
been trying to get into a relationship
and he says that he's an entrepreneur
except Adam dating the scroll and you
know I'm at a point right now where I
feel like I need to settle down I'm in
my mid-thirties said okay he says but
she she told me this I said what she
says she says it's either me or the
business because she can't stand the
fact that I'm working the way I am and
I'm running a business and I said what's
your answer says well I don't know what
do you think I should go so I'm not
gonna give you my advice
I said what's how are you wired yourself
he says Pat I don't think I can really
do this I said why do you think he says
because you're asking me to change
myself you see
when somebody says it's either me or the
business let me explain to how an
entrepreneur sees that so maybe it'll
help understand the entrepreneur says
it's either your arm or me what's more
important your I love you but I'm not
gonna cut my arm off or you're telling
me to be a whole different human being
to be with you we're not living in
biblical times I'm not gonna cut my arm
off for you if you want me this is me
this is how I come do you like it you
don't like it go find somebody else
but this sound wired I've been like this
for 22 years I've been like this for 38
years it doesn't mean I'm not gonna
change and improve myself with maturity
I am but I'm an entrepreneur I'm in the
hunt I'm going after it I'm gonna build
something special and significant for my
life and I want to build it with you but
not if you're trying to change me so on
the other side somebody may say well
they spend more time with the business
they love me they love the business more
than they love me no it's how they are
it's how they are it's how they're wired
if somebody says you know a oh babe I'm
pregnant
what do you want me to do when you're
pregnant you go through this a man may
feel like but what's so important you
the baby or me what are you talking
about this is something you know we
don't understand when the first
pregnancy we're on our third one now
sand
I get a grasp understanding of it so
who's more important me or the baby I'm
your husband that's that's an ultimatum
you don't put a mother in a position
like that you don't put an entrepreneur
in a position to say it's the business
or me they'll typically take them as who
they are for human being because the
last thing you want is date somebody and
then 10 20 years later they have
resentment then it can lead to worse
things you had somebody that decided to
change their own DNA to be with you
all because of you you have a delay time
bomb of someone that could eventually
become your biggest enemy in your life
because you try to change them I don't
recommend that one of the best
recommendations I've got before I got
married I was dating a girl at one point
and I went to one of my mentors one of
my pastors and I said hey this is this
is what I'm experiencing what do you
think so does it bother you said a lot
he said can you deal without it I said
no I cannot I can't deal with this and
he said it's just going to get more so
if you can't deal with the doubt don't
think it's going to disappear and I have
to make that decision and move on it
wasn't easy it was very difficult
because you know I really care for this
human being but I have to move on so if
somebody's really trying to change
somebody and you're an entrepreneur if
the person does change it's just a
matter of time till the person goes back
to being true to who they are you're
going to be true back to your the
entrepreneur the real entrepreneur is
going to go back me and true to
themselves okay
number eight they will miss events let
me explain to what I would I mean by
missing events one of the best examples
of a book on missing events is Total
Recall right there right behind me
Total Recall by Arnold Schwarzenegger if
we can put up a picture of it Ilia Total
Recall nourish words if you read this
book or listen to how you recommend this
book fascinating he tells a story I used
to tell the story 15 years ago
of what happened when he was coming to
America to compete for mr. Olympia and
his father passed away right before mr.
Olympia and he talks to his mother and a
mother was very disappointed that Arnold
wasn't it wasn't going
to ask her to go to the funeral and all
I said if my dad was alive and he could
see he would tell me go after your
dreams and go to my stroller yeah
family didn't understand it he goes mr.
Olympia he wins he becomes who he is and
then he goes and brings his mom and buys
a house and takes care of my mom is set
up forever in the whole family but at
that moment it didn't make any sense
that he missed that event now somebody
may watch it and say what a cold-hearted
bastard Arnold Schwarzenegger is I don't
know about that you may say oh you know
what I can't believe who you're making
him as an example forget about some of
his things that he's done the guys went
from being an immigrant to winning mr.
Olympia six or seven times to being a
Hollywood actor in some major movies to
being a governor of one of the biggest
states in America number seven economy
in the world I think I maxed out his
life in business in health in politics
in entertainment I mean what else can
you ask for this guy's done a lot of
stuff in his life and married a Kennedy
family individual you're gonna miss a
lot of events so the way I would do with
my family this is hide that my family
for many years till today what are some
events that you are not willing to
compromise that you want me to be there
Christmas Thanksgiving dot dot perfect
those are the days everything else I'm
running a business I'm gonna do my best
to be at this this this this this but
most likely I'm running no problem okay
fair enough but you got to tell me what
else you want me to be there and tell me
in advance I'm prepared for it yes so
don't expect them to make every party
you may go to a party and then he or she
may show up late why is he always late
who your friends will say things like
that to you
why she always late they're an
entrepreneur you know as an entrepreneur
you got a shot clock if you don't make
your business work it's going out of
business if it goes out of business
potentially your life savings is going
your life savings is gone you're going
back to square one even working on score
one for many many years no one wants to
do that they don't want to do that very
painful to bring up the business very
very painful and so they're going to
miss a lot of events and if you're not
comfortable with if you want them to
make every single event you may not want
to date an entrepreneur because they're
going to miss some events on the
complete opposite side they may miss
some events but long term they're going
to take you to the most ridiculous
events
ever I'm talking about stuff that you
see in movies you know if you if you
support and really develop and encourage
these guys can definitely go and
experience some events that you dream
about you read about you see in movies
you see in TV you you know people always
fantasize about these are the types of
events you will experience but if that's
not important to you know maybe there's
no value in being with an entrepreneur
if you want a life that's exhilarating
possibilities what if the unknown let's
go max out life that's the life of an
entrepreneur is what it is
at least what they're shooting for by
the way all that stuff could still not
happen so there is a risk involved you
make that decision if you want to be
involved in that risk or not number nine
your frequent travelers they're going to
be away quite regularly they travel a
lot and so you you you you you'll say
you know why is he always on the road
you know we can have to go meet with
vendors clients you know offices
business partners you know investors
they're traveling all the time they're
going to be on the road quite a lot so
you got to figure out a way to entertain
yourself because they are going to
travel if their ship they build a
national business meeting with other
people partners that's going to take
place number nine they will talk to
strangers quite regularly this is very
awkward the first time when you data an
entrepreneur somebody's invade an
entrepreneur before you'll go to a
restaurant they'll start a conversation
with a stranger why did you talk to her
baby why are you flirting with her
flirting with you that was I just I'm
talking I was talking to them seemed
like you were Friday no I'm talking to
them I didn't ask for a number with just
a pure conversation I felt like you were
talking to them for I'm not just talking
here what happened over here what was
this all about why do you talk to
everybody everywhere we go gotta stop
talking to people talk to me they're
curious people curious do you want to
learn from everybody so everything to
them is opportunities right now this is
not everybody I'm not trying to say 100%
everyone says in this box no but
generally they're curious being so they
want to learn from other people right so
they're going to talk to some strangers
and so if you're not comfortable with
that you may not like it but you got to
know that in advance to some people it's
fascinating man he wants to learn she's
always asking man she's always wanting
to learn
from people I meet so many different
people being with her being with him
that's so amazing that's that's how it
is being with an entrepreneurs wall okay
number 10 they ask a lot of questions
hey what do you think this happens you
know when you have a four year old kid
or three year old kid why are cheetahs
so fast you know why is it that you know
boys have such and such my son dear this
is daddy why is it that I have a webby
toe you know what Vito you know if you
speak Spanish where we toes is an
interesting word and you know when he's
going to the bathroom and our nanny
talks me speaks fluent Spanish now both
my boys they use some interesting for
daddy why is it that I have that I
entrepreneurs always ask you why do you
think that happened why did he do that
what was that Alma what do you think
about this you think that was good you
think that was good do you think that
was good thing we presented well you
think that was good thing I did a good
job what do you think about this for how
do you feel about that part they're
always asking questions they're always
curious their mind is always asking
questions they'll ask you a lot of
questions as well themselves next one
they'll usually attract the spotlight
the spotlight is usually going to be on
the entrepreneur I've seen many many
times many many times where this has
been a problem I don't like them getting
all the spotlight how about me
I don't like we're getting all the
spotlight how about him and you know the
entrepreneur needs to make an effort to
give the spotlight your spouse as well
all the time you need to be doing that
because that person is playing a very
important I wouldn't be where I'm at
right now I told this to my father
there's not many people I could have
married not many people because I know
myself I'm self aware of myself to know
what bothers me and how I'm wired that I
have to make sure the person I married
was someone who knew how I'm wired
not necessarily them how I'm wired not
because I'm more important no because I
know my faults I know my issues I'm very
self aware of how I'm wired I know that
but I wouldn't be where I'm at without
the partner so you keep this in mind
this is not a single guy doing this
video with somebody may watch this and
say it's pat against this and no it's
not Pat's not against this Pat's about
doing it the right way so you make sure
this doesn't continuously happen and
both people are disappointed it's just
knowing how are you wired and how is
that person wired so I'm all about
having healthy marriages I'm all about
having healthy
relationships but I think too often were
not prepared in knowing what to expect
and we're not self-aware as
entrepreneurs and we're not open with
the other person how we're wired you
know the first three to six months will
lie to each other you notice when you go
on a date oh I love flowers too baby oh
my gosh you don't understand what kind
of flowers I like the most sometimes I
just like to look at the grass see grow
it's so amazing to me it shows the power
of God and you know what I like what do
you like oh my goodness you know the
other day I was watching these birds
chirping and when I was watching these
birds chirp I mean we will make up the
dumbest things and dates okay I highly
recommend if it's serious don't talk
about the birds chirp and if you can't
stand the birds chirp and I'm not going
to tell you haven't used that line
before but I didn't use the line when I
was clear on what I wanted I was self
aware of myself no one cares about birds
chirpin if you don't care about the
birds chirpin okay
and so but anyways I think kind of get
the idea you gonna you're gonna have
attract a lot of the spotlight that
bothers you it's gonna bother this
doesn't mean they kind of like you also
have you in your identity there's not a
problem with you having your own
identity so it's not like you can't have
your own idea and that's your they're
just wire they tend to track the
spotlight but it brings attention to
everybody so you if you also have a
cause that you want to do something that
can bring attention to your cause as
well if you're clear about your cause
point number 12 your friends and family
may either love them or hate them
let me explain to what I mean by this
just don't with statistic I want to look
up a number that was done by you who did
this study who did this study was it it
was a study done let's put the link on
the bottom it was a study done by
inc.com I'll put on the bottom with the
link I wanted to find out what
percentage of Americans were
entrepreneurs I think about this 27
million Americans are entrepreneurs when
it comes down to the adults 14 percent
of American workers are entrepreneurs so
what does that mean to you and I here's
what it means to me this is high
introduced number that means 86 percent
of people don't know what it is to be
married to an entrepreneur 14 percent of
our entrepreneurs that means 86 percent
have never dated or married married mid
they may have
they're no longer with them they don't
know what it is to be with an
entrepreneur so the advice your friends
and family may give you they're coming
from a place of I'm married a nine to
fiver so their feedback to you is how
their nine-to-five or was that is not a
person you want to get feedback from I
had somebody would come up to and say
well this person told me to do this when
asked does that person with ninety five
years why are you taking advice from
somebody that's working nine to five on
how to make your marriage work when
you're not working nine to five you're
an athlete you're an artist you're a
creator that person is not nothing wrong
with them they're supporting cast but
you're the one that's in the absolute
stadium fighting playing big getting
crushed
getting killed getting torn up getting
hurt at times and here's somebody that's
trying to tell you how for you to make
your life work as an entrepreneur that
doesn't make any sense to me
ask feedback form and all the timer that
made their married marriage work in the
relationship work how they went about
making it work and they had healthy kids
being a race that's the person you want
to ask feedback from when it comes down
to something like this so know that if
only fourteen percent American workers
are entrepreneurs that means only eighty
six percent of people know what it is to
have an entrepreneur and their family so
if they have if the girl you're dating
or the guy you're dating you're the
entrepreneur that person's you know not
if if his or her parents neither one of
them have been entrepreneurs it will
always be measured my father was always
there my mom was this my but they're
nine to five it's not a fair assessment
but she may say I totally know my father
was an entrepreneur bump that's good so
what kind of hours would you dad worked
at that perfect okay you know I asked a
couple the other I took him on and the
girl who her father was an entrepreneur
that very well making six seven hundred
thousand dollars day as a doctor she
said well my dad you know you know he he
was always coming home really yes hmm
how old was your dad when you were born
he was in his mid 40s had he already
been making his money or he was already
established build his business okay so
your dad wanted to go till it's mid 40s
build a business of a half a million six
hundred thousand dollar year income and
then you experienced the final product
yes so you were not there in the startup
days when he was building up business no
so can you see how unfair it is for you
to measure your spouse that you're
thinking about
married to to your father at 45 well
he's only 32 never thought about it that
way so maybe your mother was a little
bit more patient with the results and
maybe you need to be a little bit more
patient you know what good counsel go
talk to your dad and see what the time
was she went and talked to the dad came
back since yes my that was in a hunt by
the time I got there the hunt went lower
because he was already at six seven
hundred thousand dollar income his goal
was to get to that point great and that
was his goal but you got to know that
most people don't know what it is to be
within entrepreneurs so when you're
asking counsel from somebody else a
friend or relative should I or should I
know would he think about him mom or
damn it he works way too hard she works
way too hard they're gonna say that cuz
they don't know what it is to be with an
entrepreneur
we should get take counsel from the
right people in areas that they have
experience in number thirteen have
strong opinions they have very strong
opinions they're probably enough strong
opinions possibly about politics about
finance about economy about health about
most they're typically strong opinions
the reason why they have typically have
strong opinions because no one gives
everything to one thing unless if
there's a strong conviction in them that
produces this drive this passion to give
that much energy and effort to doing
something that's cost from a lot of
strong opinions having created over the
years some may not have it but most are
gonna have strong opinions and that
doesn't mean you have to agree with it
or not it just means they have strong
opinions if some of them are that
critical where you and him totally think
about polluted politics and complete
different ways somebody brought up the
idea of the identity and what's more
important marrying somebody that could
be similar faith or similar economic
system said I think it's more important
marrying somebody that's on a similar
economical system they said why it's
very hard for a capitalist and a
communist to be married for a long time
very hard very very hard but if a
Christian marries a Catholic similar
beliefs Ten Commandments similar beliefs
if a LDS marries a you know a
Scientologist
yes it's very different but if they both
believe in capitalism and hard work it's
going to probably work out
still it's don't be promiscuous don't
cheat don't steal don't do this don't do
this it's a lot of the similarities
there so I think it's important the
opinions being the same but they're
typically in have strong opinions now
point number fourteen
they despise lazy people they don't just
not like them they despise lazy people
they don't like lazy people they cannot
stand lazy people if they date somebody
that they even get a feeling that this
person may be lazy they just want the
victory entrepreneurs can typically read
through the BS just keep that in mind
you're going to be able to read through
the BS that'll be a very very
short-lived relationship if somebody
else is very lazy they're not a fan of
dating lazy people they also want you to
be in a hunt for something you know they
want to date somebody that's also in the
hunt because they want to learn from you
as well so they don't want it to be just
about that and then last but not least
they get bored very quickly they get
bored very very quickly so they want
somebody that's also in it hungry
growing improving you know feeding not
feeding food feeding information feeding
knowledge like you're also learning
you're also growing you're also
spontaneous
you're also doing things you're also up
for doing hey let's go out there and
travel there they're typically very
spontaneous they don't like a you know
being bored too much and so you know
they're they're always wanting to do
something so it's about learning
something constantly learning something
is what it is that they want to do so
you got to keep this couple things in
mind I'll wrap it up with this year I'll
wrap it over this year it pretty much
comes down to one thing is if you a lot
of times you hear things saying well he
married her and she changed him and now
he is amazing right I think an
entrepreneur marries somebody and they
change by choice because of love because
of experiences because of somebody in
their corner because of loyalty because
of support because behind the closed
doors this person really supports them
it's almost like the movie Field of
Dreams
where Kevin Costner says I heard this
voice if you build it they will come and
then she says well if you did hear that
voice let's take our savings and build a
field now you got to know that's
absolutely ludicrous but behind every
amazing entrepreneur that does something
big that everybody knows about I
guarantee you there's a even a stronger
partner
woman husband they marry that back them
up that gave him the strength that they
have I guarantee you you may see the
final product but you don't see the
spouse I promise you meet the spouse
you're gonna say wolf now I get it now I
totally get it
because he lifts him up because she
lifts her up cuz she lifts him up he
lifts her up you can totally see this
right so but if you try to change the
entrepreneur they wired that way for a
reason if you try to say you have
problems you have issues your mental you
may be sick you may be this they already
know they have problems you don't need
to tell them their problems but they're
typically self-aware of themselves
sooner than later preferably up for them
to be sooner than later normally it's
sooner because they've been told that
all their lives you have ADHD you don't
pay attention you paying attention to
butterfly it's not the first time
somebody told them that so after that
hearing that a couple thousand times you
realize maybe I am different but if you
do have the courage to data and
entrepreneur know this the same way you
get a luxury of marrying a soldier that
you yourself also have the honor to say
at least my spouse my partner serves my
country and brings safety and freedom to
a lot of people that's honorable what he
does or what she does so they may be
gone for two years to Iraq or two years
to Afghanistan or two years to whatever
place and you may not see them with kids
you're gonna see your entrepreneur the
militaries you don't see them you know
the cause is a bigger cause you may be
married to an athlete you know an
athlete the life is a very interesting
life an artist an actor a pastor I'm you
you get stats like Billy Graham who
baptized 210 million people around the
world for his religion he believes in
Christianity yes
you better believe us being away from
the family quite a lot but the wife has
to support that or else this is not
going to happen you know history books
are not gonna remember this man that
came and did this and goes to Korea and
1.2 million people show up for what you
know when you when you have athletes
that make some world changes that do
something special behind closed doors it
was somebody played a very very
important role in MAGIX life Magic
Johnson's life I mean this list goes on
and on and on so there are a lot of pain
initially
but by far there's a lot more fruits of
the labor long-term than pain so if you
do see interest in wanting to date this
entrepreneur just anticipate all these
15 things that could happen and don't be
surprised by I could probably have
another 50 things on this money just
giving you 50 because I don't want to
overwhelm you just know it's gonna be
slightly different but I would love to
hear comments from you the entrepreneur
on what else you would add to this list
that maybe I didn't and I would love to
hear from you the partner dating an
entrepreneur you know I got some
questions and requests and can you mind
doing a video and saying how an
entrepreneur should be dealing with
their family life and ours all this
stuff you got questions post them on the
bottom I do respond back to pretty much
every single question that's being posed
maybe 3 o'clock in the morning or 4:00
in the morning but we do get back to the
comments that are being posted and by
the way if you haven't subscribed to
this channel please do so on the bottom
if you if you saw value in this video
you can pay back and show value yourself
to me by subscribing to the channel and
sharing the video with other people that
may also see value from the crazy life
of dating and entrepreneur with that
being said thanks for watching take care